my point is that we are the privileged
to be able to say that that is our
identity however some people don't have
that and I feel like being a minority
and knowing what it feels like for
somebody to be like no you're less than
or no no no wait wait let me finish okay
so someone's saying that's the way it
should be no I have a problem with that
because well no if I was on the other
foot and I was born as a as a man and I
want to identify as a woman I would be
pissed off if somebody told me that I
can't be what I want to be nobody's
saying that nobody's saying that
nobody's saying that but you are because
I'm not saying I'm saying you are not
object you are objectively not that
thing if you if you were sitting here
telling me that you are white right I'll
be like you're you're not white you you
can say that you are you can feel like
it you can act like it whatever that
means you could even go and bleach your
skin you could you could do whatever you
like you have the right to do that
you're an adult you have the right to do
whatever you want you can have cosmetic
procedures you can do what you like but
you are not you are not white
objectively you're you're not